samira es wohl kalt die auch machen über
die jacke zu murat jacke oder schafe uns
ja schon kommen es ist wahr
aber irgendwie sieht so aus wie
peruanischen spieler also wir sind die
zielgerade in der eiszeit
aber uns ist ganz warm so mehr geld denn
wir haben heute wieder alle motiv schade
für euch und ihr könnt die
wahrscheinlicheren vorstellung für
welchen film
ich habe ein motiv torte zum film ice
age gebacken und dekoriert und möchte
ich heute zeigen wie das alles
funktioniert um dies alles geht und ich
habe mir überlegt wie backen scrat das
ist ja dieses eichhörnchen also zwischen
eichhörnchen aber es ist ziemlich
hässlich wobei süß aussieht findet
naja egal jedenfalls kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich alle scrat aus den ice
ich will man es doch der jedes mal - und
auch dieses mal ist es so und nur ja
bauder dieses mal ein bisschen ist kann
schon als sage ja irgendwie irgendwie
sich an mich oder nicht der eher kleines
bisschen an bord ist um ihren fest kann
man auch sagen jedenfalls wird er ins
universum katapultiert zerstört dort
es läuft eine kettenreaktion ab und
dadurch für die eiszeit zerstört und
deswegen mindestens die anderen
hauptdarsteller alles tun und begeben
sich auf ein abenteuer und werden die
eiszeit eben wieder retten und wir schon
ganz kurzen trailer an oder und wir
übrigens einer meiner lieblingsfilme
total lustig und gucken wir mal kurz
rein
schmidt ich das problem aus da ist sie
die mutter aller asteoriden straßen auf
uns zu darf ich mal diesen sommer es ist
unser
der gang war keine panik diese tafel
enthält die schlüssel wird ihn zur
absturzstelle
so viel kosmische hinweise und überlegen
wie wir das verhindern können welche
blöd man denkt er könnte einen asteroid
aufhalten
die angezählten reingeht klingt das ende
der eiszeit während er mal eben ranch
werden wir da oben am himmel in
sicherheit genau wie die flächen alter
schwede ist erst der beginn
wo sind wir hier in sofia einer neuen
zeit die lösung zur rettung der welt ist
hier ja aber zuerst meine nase ist
gefährlichen an meinem buch von betty
century fox und blue sky studios dann
auf gäste dass etwa die typen die die
welt treffen sollen wir sie nicht cool
aus wie in just heute nicht das auf die
fresse fallen der strategie ist das
entscheidende kapitel
der eisigsten filmreihe aller zeiten du
mich erwähnt und meine blühen die
allgemeine augen ich hab schmetterlinge
im bauch
mir wird ganz schlecht
lasst meine herde passiert das hat ihr
werdet schon sehen
die gäste blieben weiter mit dem bereich
sales kollision voraus
also ich hab den kurzen einblick in den
film bekommen
ich finde auf jeden fall sehr
interessant sehr spannend und ich denke
wir werden auf jeden fall anschauen also
bisher waren alle teile immer lustig und
vor allem immer tolle familienfilme und
ich hab jetzt wie gesagt diesen scrat
gebackene 3d motiv torte und es sieht
wahrscheinlich ganz kompliziert aus aber
im prinzip habe ich wirklich nur den
einen tag die böden den boden
vorgebacken die creme gemacht und am
nächsten tag nochmal etwa vier stunden
dekoriert und die torte war schon fertig
gefilmt hätten vielleicht in drei
schwestern fertig gehabt auf jeden fall
ja und ich so richtig gehen ja und sie
schmeckt auch sehr gut denn im innern
habe ich eine haselnuss torte mit einer
nogat creme und überzogen mit von land
und dekoriert mit modelle schokolade und
wenn ihr jetzt wissen nur durch diese
torte gebacken hat dann schaut jetzt
einfach weiter
juni spielt zu gewinnen gibt er den
hasse lustig brauche ich 200 gramm
weiche butter 200 gramm zucker eine
prise salz 4 ja etwas vanille extrakt
100 gramm zartbitterschokolade 200 gramm
haselnüsse ein päckchen backpulver 125
milliliter milch und 200 gramm mehl
zuerst gebe ich jetzt die weiche butter
den zucker das salz und dass man ihn
fragt in eine rührschüssel und lass es
für zwei bis drei minuten kriegen spüren
wenn ihnen dazwischen zeigt kann ich
jetzt schon mal die haare und ist auf
einmal und anschließend in einer pfanne
ohne fett rösten bis sie tolerieren und
ich bin immer ganz gerne ganze
haselnüsse weil das aroma viel besser
ist
und dann kann ich jetzt noch die
schokolade zerkleinern und kurz beiseite
stellen
jetzt kommen auch die eier mit in den
teig und dadurch ist ein einfach zum
anderen ein und für jedes ei etwa eine
halbe minute
jetzt fahre ich noch backpulver und mehl
und dann kommen alle zutaten gemeinsam
in die rührschüssel und werden mit dem
teig verrührt
den fertigen teig für dich jetzt in
meine vorbereitete backform ich habe den
programmen auf 22 cm eingestellt und den
bereits mit backpapier eingeschlagen
und so wird der teig jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 30 minuten gebacken
ich werde auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe machen und wird in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die creme
vorbereiten
für den werde ich jetzt eine nuss nougat
gallasch erstellen und nehme dafür 200
gramm schlagsahne 400 und 200 gramm
vollmilch kuvertüre es geht jetzt auch
ganz schnell ich werde es die sahne kurz
aufkochen lassen und sobald dieser den
kopf sehe ich sie vom herd herunter und
kann jetzt nogat und die vollmilch
schokolade ein hören
jetzt so lange rhön ist alles
geschmolzen ist
an
die creme ist fertig und ich kann selbst
abdecken
da kann sie nämlich über nacht einfach
in der küche stehen bleiben oder in
einem kühlen raum falls die küche jetzt
zu warm ist der komponist mittlerweile
auch gebacken und den werde ich jetzt
einmal vom torten hand lösen
das geht am besten mit einem tortenring
messe
kelch den torten rahmen lösen und den
abdecken dieser zimmertemperatur
angenommen hat anschließend verpacke ich
ihnen umstellung dann in den kühlschrank
über nacht und kann dann morgen die
torte gefühl und dekorieren der
kuchenteig durch gekühlt und auch die
cremes abgekühlt jetzt kann ich sie
bereits auf eine tortenplatte setzen und
zwar nimmt jetzt hier ein dickes
kickboard das werde ich auch später
gleich zum servieren nehmen auf das
skateboard streite ich jetzt ein
bisschen von der creme floss in die
mitte damit der kuchenteig gleichzeit
anklebt und jetzt nehme ich den
kuchenteig und wird in ersten mal durch
schneiden am besten geht es immer mit
einer torten säge ich werde jetzt
zweimal durch durchschneiden
den oberen erst mal kurz weg setzten den
unteren setzt sich jetzt bereits auf die
tortenplatte und kann dann den oberen
teil nochmal durchschneiden
jetzt kann ich die torte befüllen ich
habe jetzt hier ein bisschen
aprikosenmarmelade schon erhitzt dass
streiche ich jetzt auch mit rein
das macht den kuchen noch mal extra
saftig und bei mir zu hause ist es jetzt
wirklich ein bisschen warm deswegen lege
ich jetzt zum abkühlen eps von der
kühltruhe unter den top damit die creme
die garage nicht immer so weich wird
jetzt kommt zuerst ein bisschen
aprikosenmarmelade auf die torte
jetzt ein bisschen creme drauf diese so
ein bisschen zu weich wie gesagt weil es
hier drin einfach sehr warm ist
aber ich werde sie gleich zum
bestreichen noch kurz kühl stellen aber
für die füllung ist das jetzt gar nicht
schlimm
gut verteilen und diese nougat creme
macht die tortur richtig lecker also
dann schmeckt richtig eine haselnuss
macht schokolade und es schmeckt am ende
richtig gut
jetzt den zweiten teil drauf sitzen und
dann das gleiche nochmal als erste große
formulare und dann lukat
die torte isst befüllt und jetzt muss er
erstmal in den kühlschrank zum fest
werden für etwa eine halbe stunde und
die dazwischen zeit zeige ich euch schon
mal einen ganz tollen trick ist
eigentlich kein trick und zwar braucht
jetzt eine vorlage oder eine schablone
für die torte dann geht es nämlich viel
viel einfacher
deswegen habe ich mir ein paar fotos
ausgedruckt und zwar nimmt ihr am besten
immer fotos wo man die person oder eben
die figur von vorne sieht das ist
natürlich etwas schwierig wenn man was
aus dem film raus nimmt damit soll für
scrat denn sieht man es von vorne so
eine art porträtbild und das habe ich
jetzt vergrößert so dass es auf etwa
eben 220 cm durchmesser kommt und habt
ihr noch andere bilder ausgedruckt wo
ich dann später einfach immer mal wieder
schauen kann und so ein bisserl ja nach
modellieren kann man sieht ja bei ihm
zum beispiel das eine ziemlich lange
schnauze hat und die werden wir
natürlich auch versuchen nachzumachen
das nehme ich das bild was ich als
orientierung nehmen
das ist jetzt genau das große hier und
es muss sich jetzt einmal gut
ausschneiden
die haare können jetzt weg ich brauche
ist einfach nur die umrisse
jetzt ist die torte gekühlt und ich kann
setzt zurechtschneiden jetzt nehmt ihr
euch diese schablone als vorlage
jetzt sieht zwar noch ein bisschen klein
aus aber der kopf wieder gleich
dreidimensional und dann sieht es
richtig toll aus jetzt müsst ihr hier
ganz vorsichtig entlang schneiden
zwar werde ich jetzt beim schneiden
darauf achten dass sich symmetrisch
macht und wenn ich jetzt die schablone
anschauen mal die zähne so übereinander
legt sich dass sie gar nicht symmetrisch
ist weil einfach ist bild nicht so von
frontal fotografiert ich sage ich jetzt
mal
deswegen nehme ich jetzt nur diese
rechte seite die einfach so ein bisschen
frontaler ist so das lege ich mir jetzt
hier drauf und kann es hier so ein
bisschen größer mache ich sie aber
zurecht schneiden die ohren lassen wir
weg die werden nämlich später gemacht
es trägt die schablone um hand hier und
jetzt richtig schablone um
m
jetzt kann man den rest erst mal
wegschneiden
und diese teile erst mal noch aufheben
die brauchen wir gleich noch für die
schnauze
jetzt könnt ihr mit der übrigen creme
und mit dem kuchen resten arbeiten und
bis jetzt diesen kopf so ein bisschen
dreidimensionale formen also hinten
setze ich doch noch mal dieses kleine
stück dran denn der kopf soll eher
rundlich sein und die augen soll dann
später so bisher hervorschauen
da muss hier die schnauze dran
und damit die chance jetzt stabil genug
wird stecke ich gleich noch einen cake
pops tick rein
dort jetzt komplett einmal mit der gage
eingestrichen aber damit wir am
stabilität zunimmt werde ich jetzt
erstmal kühlen und dann nochmal die
feinarbeiten machen
bei den feinheiten muss ich jetzt bei
der teure darauf achten dass sie etwas
runder wird und somit etwas plastischer
wirkt und das mache ich jetzt mit hilfe
des messers und eben auch mit der
übrigen creme
also habe ich hier die grundstrukturen
erstmal etwas runter gemacht jetzt kommt
hier unten noch einmal dran denn
ansonsten werde sehr unrealistisch
deswegen nimmt noch mal die kuchen reste
und setzt die krankenschwestern wieder
zurecht
kühl und ich werde jetzt schon mal die
zwischenzeit nutzen um die zähne
herzustellen
dafür habe ich jetzt weiß er modelliert
schokolade bereits weiß geknetet und
nehmen mit jeder die vorlage und die
weiße modelle schokolade passt auch
farblich perfekt an die zähne sind nicht
rein reist sondern eher so wie ein
dreckiges weiß der frist nicht gesehen
hat wird seine lange rolle erst mal
wegen der größe und kann mich da jetzt
immer daran orientieren und bisschen
größer kann ich sie machen
ich kann sie dann immer noch
wegschneiden und jetzt nimmt ja auch
immer diese vorlage und form jetzt die
zähne schön nach also nach unten hin
spitz und oben eben etwas breiter
ein
mit
jetzt muss ich hier oben nur noch die
schnauze formen das muss man aber alles
nur grob machen weil nämlich später von
dort alles überdenken wird
die torte sitzt weiter mit ganache
gestrichen
jetzt habe ich hier ein kilo vanille
fondant der passt farblich und geschmack
ich natürlich auch zeit mit mir dazu und
den rolle ich jetzt aus allerdings nicht
so dünn wie ich sonst immer aus rolle
sondern schon so etwa 5 mm
jetzt kann ich ein fondant ganz
vorsichtig zu überlegen
jetzt beginnt ihr hier oben und streicht
ganz langsam nach oben
den überschuss nämlich jetzt mit einem
marzipan messer weg
jetzt einfach mit den händen und mit
modelle werkzeug so ein bisschen die
ecken und kanten und vor allem diese
gesichtszüge ein bisschen nach formen
jetzt die augen zusammen nämlich jetzt
werde die schablone und schneidet die
augen daher raus dann weiß ich nämlich
wie groß ich sie formen muss
und jetzt könnt ihr mit einem
zahnstocher mit einem modell werkzeug
oder mit einer gabel noch das fell
strukturieren
nein
die tat steht jetzt erst mal noch im
kühlschrank jetzt kann ich schon einmal
die nach reformen und zwar mache ich die
aus milchschokolade weil die immer schön
aushärtet jetzt habe ich mir bereits
einen großen ball von der modellierte
weggenommen und zwar als orientierung
immer wieder die zeichnung nehmen und
natürlich auch ans original halten
die nase ist jetzt nach oben hin etwas
spitz und unten etwas breiter
und mit dem modell werkzeug wird es
jetzt auch wieder ausgefahren
jetzt nehme ich die überschüsse an der
torte weg das geht am besten mit einem
marzipan messer
und jetzt kann ich die torte ein
bisschen spazieren dafür nehme ich jetzt
pulver farben
ich hab es keinen schönen b strom
deswegen habe ich jetzt so ein dunkelrot
mit einem orange und noch etwas schwarz
und kann jetzt die traber ganz trocken
aufbot
nach noch befestigt dann müssen jetzt
erst mal schauen wo sie hingehört und
die nase ist jetzt aufzeichnung auch so
dass er nach oben zeigt also dass ich
wenn ich sie jetzt von oben anschauen
die nasenlöcher von unten sehen da werde
ich jetzt auch ankleben mit etwas
essbarem kleber
und hier um die nase herum kommen jetzt
noch ein bisschen schwarz boden
als nächstes sind jetzt die augen dran
dafür habe ich jetzt weißen von bar oder
fondant mit etwas 10c pulver als
zellulose pulver verknetet und daraus
warum ich jetzt eine kugel da orientiert
ihr euch wieder an der schablone das
heißt ich habe schon mal ein stückchen
abgerissen und einfach mal geschaut ob
es von der größe her fast kommt ein
bisschen kleber hier in die augenhöhle
dann kommt da diese kugel rein
der hat ja auch so ganz große kugel
augen
die euch einen runden gegenstand
entweder nennt deckel oder eine
spritztour zum beispiel und markiert
jetzt das auge also die er ist bei mir
geht es jetzt ganz gut mit dem
spritzbeutel adapter und dann mittig
markieren
und die ihres werde ich jetzt mit
lebensmittel farbstiften anmalen
das ist ja so ein schöner braun ton und
da werde mit gelb braun und schwarz
arbeiten
jetzt lebe ich noch mal schwarze modell
ihr schokolade und schlechter zwei
kreise aus und es wird an die pupille
jetzt kommt noch ein kleiner weißer
punkt in die pupille den mache ich es
auch auswandern
jetzt habe ich noch mal etwas von ihrer
freundin im bett noch die augenlider
formen und zwar zuerst eine kugel und
dann eine lange schlange formen und
litern angegeben und auch mit der pulver
farbe etwas bewundern
jetzt mache ich hier am maul weiter und
bekommt ein paar zähne hin
die habe ich jetzt so geformt ich nehme
immer ein kleines stück modelle
schokolade form ist zu einer kugel und
an seinem tropfen und das ende wird dann
immer mit dem finger so ein bisschen
abgeflacht und die kann ich jetzt hier
rechts und links noch ankleben
bevor ich jetzt die ohren noch zuletzt
forme werde ich jetzt erstmal das
skateboard überziehen und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier ein bisschen puderzucker und
füllte etwas wasser rein und machen
richtig dickflüssigen bus und s streiche
ich dann gleich komplett auf das
skateboard damit einfach so bis nach
schnee und nach es aussieht weil wir bei
der 111 sind
und damit der ice effekt etwas größer
wird streue ich da noch etwas haken
zucker drauf
das habe ich jetzt hier weiße modell
schokolade bereits ausgerollt und habe
jetzt auch rosa modelle schokolade mit
weißer modelle schokolade verknetet für
die ohren habe ich jetzt keine
schablonen und das mache ich es einfach
nach augenmaß ist schneidig hier erstmal
zwei teile und lege jetzt die beiden
teile übereinander dann kann ich nämlich
gleich richtig abmessen und jetzt werde
ich zuerst es eine ausschneiden und noch
einmal drauflegen und das andere
ausschneiden
das muss jetzt am dreieck werden
mit den fingern jetzt einfach ein
bisschen über den rand fahren dann wird
es ein bisschen weiter und sieht nicht
so aus geschnitten aus
jetzt den rosinen teilnehmen den auch
ausschneiden und darüber kleben
jetzt auch noch ein bisschen mehr
modelle werkzeug drüber formen
das puder farbe bepinselt
wisst ihr ohren am an den rändern wir
ein bisschen zusammen klicken und dann
ankleben
jetzt werden eigentlich nur noch die
szene die kommen hier direkt ins maul
es haut ist jetzt fertig und jetzt kann
ich sie abschneiden
ok riesen teller gegeben
ein kleines kuchenstück drauf aber was
soll so darfst trotzdem probieren möchte
probieren sie mir okay dann darf der
papa probieren und ich kann euch schon
mal vom gewinnspiel erzählen also zu
gewinnen gibt 3 x 2 kinokarten für den
film ice age und zwar könnt ihr an dem
gewinnspiel teilnehmen wenn ihr folgende
frage richtig beantwortet also während
im video wurden immer wieder einzeln
eingeblendet und wenn ihr jetzt sagen
können wie viele es insgesamt waren also
wie viele einzelnen wurden im video
eingeblendet dann schreibt mir die
kommentare und dann nehmen sie auch
schon mal zum gewinnspiel teil und die
gewinner werde ich dann schriftlich
benachrichtigen
und ja ich drücke euch allen ganz fest
die daumen
und wie schmeckt riecht die phasen musik
italien laufe schon mal gemacht gehabt
eine hase lustig
also das ist eigentlich so glaube ich
die erste haselnuss torte mit lukas
füllung und ich finde sie passt eben
auch perfekt zu dem film ok ich glaube
ich normal stück doch ich glaube auch
wieder frisch ist
er macht ja nix wir können jetzt die
ganze torte essen und falls jetzt lust
bekommen habe die torte nach zu backen
dann geht auch sallys - blog.de da steht
noch einmal die genauen mengenangaben
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachkochen und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten mal bis dann muss macht stets
essen wie ein stück oder samira
apa